[Music]
this is the new place yes how you like
it a lot of land out here oh yeah this
ain't like the dream home
i like it it works it's close to the
girls that's the plus
there's a lot of memories we made
the only reason i did not tell y'all in
production that i was moving because one
i needed to do it quick it was the only
one available and when i get it all
together i'm gonna tell the girls i'm
here in georgia i wanna let them know
that i'm established and i'm here and
i'm you know going to be here june are
you in love
yes what yes
yes i have to say yes what jasmine was
in love
i don't know
it's a little too i mean
what
what i keep trying to tell you what
about what are we trying not to make
happen
if i did i wouldn't tell you right now
you are in love
i love you i got love for you i don't
know i wouldn't tell you like that's
been a month
hell you might have just reeled me all
the way in you know what i mean
whatever there you go huh
people may think that you know i'm
moving fast okay one i've known justin
we were friends we got to know each
other we both needed a fresh new start
justin isn't like the other people
before him i'm not
doing 100
and they're only doing 10
it feels like it's a hundred hundred and
for once i'm
one thousand percent
so it's been really nice
so the girls know you're here and where
your house is and all that stuff um no
the girls do not know where our house is
i don't even know about justin yet so
you need to keep your mouth shut but i
want to surprise them when i'm ready
i mean i'm hoping that with the girls
living closer
that we can work on things but who knows
what the future holds